hey guys what's up I'm a lot of welcome
to my channel right now i am in paris
games week it's currently closed so this
is technically day zero convention
actually starts tomorrow and i feel like
you know all of this space around me is
going to be very very filled with people
very very quickly so far I'm just
impressed at how big it is it's
not as big as games call or a dream but
it's a lot bigger than I expected it to
be
so we just left the trouble that wasn't
that one to do that and now at the
hospital if it's all of these
presentations
just got my wristband
free show
press conference and this is
free show body that I have ever been to
play nice anything free this is amazing
and I guess only in Paris right
she'll stripped off the PlayStation
paris games week for us
that's one of the best for us
conferences I move it to the variety of
games was amazing
but by the time you watch this you have
already seen my highlights video
and then right now we are going to head
back to the actual explore because I
have some behind closed doors previews
of some of those games
wild outdoors watch the games are
absolutely
Iron Fist dude right now it's about
ten-thirty
that i have a ten day or 11
before I go back to the hotel
a little
you
here today that it wasn't a yesterday
obvious reasons I face
to run straight to my playstation beyond
behind
my phone with my station beyond I played
until
the playroom game we mustn't forget the
headset the other three had constructed
under way home contender Lynde and Harry
Potter Ferguson
I Yahoo's with my highlight of that was
absolutely amazing but i'll upload a
video with more descriptive impressions
for the PlayStation VR games I played so
far I we fell with the lobby uncharted
show you guys
community events basically place that
people can play uncharted 4 multiplayer
without the crazy queues of the show for
during the actual open sessions and some
drinks as well there's a bar kind of
over there but seriously how cool is a
setup
super fun side learn both Tribeca and no
one will help you at this tiny little
community event
I just finished playing on China to
multiplayer and I think it's really cool
the traversal particularly is really
really cool being able to jump between
things like some kind of monkey in a
multiplayer experience is something
that's definitely need to me and makes
it a lot of fun to actually move around
and math doesn't just feel like they're
moving between targets all the time so
that's the uncharted 4 community event
wrapped up right now I'm going to go
back to the hotel room and edit some
videos but i thought i would show you
how weird it is with everything actually
this empty it's even emptier than it was
on the media day like the lights are off
are you serious who did that there's a
bin right there oh my god
the [ __ ] is this transmutation circle
trying to bring your mom back to life
that was a full metal alchemist
reference that if you got it you're an
excellent human
so today is the third day that I would
effectively be going to Paris games week
but because I was up all last night
editing and uploading my highlights
video I slept the hell in and I now have
to be at the airport in like two and a
half hours so I'm actually not going to
go so now I have to get on my plane the
first plane to Hong Kong second plane
goes to Melbourne I'll be flying for
about 20 hours and i arrived in
Melbourne four packs at 730am my first
panel at pax is at twelve-thirty it's
going to be terrible but I'll make it
through I think I'm also djing three
nights in a row of a packed weekend and
oh it's gonna be messy so I'm glad but I
just had that sleeper than this glorious
glorious hotel [ __ ] but I'm Alana thank
you guys for watching I will have lots
of more in-depth coverage of all of the
stuff that I checked out coming over the
next few weeks I will see you guys next
time bye